chaos in Chicago over Biden's border
crisis residents taking over a council
meeting Furious over efforts to stop a
referendum that would allow the people
to directly decide whether the windy
city should remain a sanctuary City and
putting that question on the ballot next
Sprint do you as a resident of the city
of Chicago believe that we should remain
a sanctuary City it's a simple
question but the community outrage the
city's far-left mayor Brandon Johnson
ultimately blocked the measure that
would allow residents to weigh in
they'll be meeting again in the next
hour so we'll see how this all shakes
out Dana I thought you were supposed to
kind of serve the people if the people
want something maybe you should let them
and want to listen I mean that's an idea
I think that it's pretty interesting
that they never thought that anyone
would call their Bluff on the sanctuary
city right they're not a Border Town
they thought it'll always what they
could be uh virtue signaling as much as
they want and then all of a sudden you
have this this is a top issue for voters
going into 2024 and for the Biden
Administration I can't for the life of
me think what it would take for Biden to
actually care you even had Brandon
Johnson the farle mayor go to the White
House last week he got nothing big Goose
EG that's all he got they might be able
to get a little bit more money for the
border patrol but there's no policy
changes coming so you have to wonder
what in the world would get President
Biden to change course On the Border I
I'm actually dumbfounded by it Janine
they're going to have the DNC I believe
in Chicago oh that ought to be a real
hoot I clean up the migrants like they
did the homeless in San Francisco yeah
I'm sure they're going to have to do
that but you know I always thought that
especially with the Democrats there's
something called direct democracy you
know where the Democrats feel like you
know they are they they've got a say and
that the people who represent them
represent them for their best interest
and when you see a new a new mayor like
Brandon Johnson I what is he in a year
now and he's basically shutting down the
opportunity of Chicago residents
American citizens to have a say because
they are losing they're on the losing
end of this where the illegals get what
$40 million a month for Health Care
housing meals head head start and all
that stuff and they end up losing some
of their uh some of the ability to have
their kids go to whatever it's Parks or
whatever it may be so that the illegals
can come in and the mayor won't even let
them vote on the thing it is uh it is
really amazing and my understanding Dana
maybe I'm wrong I thought that they
wanted five billion when the Mayors went
and I thought they came out with 1.4
billion um and but even that I mean they
should be the people should be given a
choice that's what democracy is yeah we
were hearing about democracy for years
Greg from the Democrats
now no one's allowed to vote it's weird
I was listening to the city council and
all I heard was let's go
Brandon uh they just replaced Lori
Lightfoot with a scarier sequel you know
it's like alien and illegal aliens so
it's not about the person just the
person it's also about their policies
that tell you that you're racist if you
speak out against the destruction to
your cities through illegal illegal
immigration that's hard for me to say
this this is one this this is again a
ision based upon the idea of one party
rule without a republican influence
right it's like a classroom full of
delinquent kids you need to have two
responsible parties there contrasting
systems people that you disagree with to
keep the city in a comfortable middle so
you're able to hear the other side and
then work with them but without
Republicans every city you're seeing is
veering into Progressive decline it's
because they have absolutely no system
in place they just have these lofty
goals but know where to get it is it
racist to not let black Americans in
Chicago
vote yeah but that's not what's
happening and why not yes it is no it's
not well first of all well I have a lot
of things to say and that's what usually
happens when I go last so a city an
American city Republican leadership
until a little while ago Jacksonville a
murder capital huge homeless pop okay
it's accurate I except proves a
rule yes in your face Jessica Colorado
Colorado Spring let's go let's Tango
that's two all right Big Deal Democrats
accept election results and want
everyone to be able to vote look what
happened in Mississippi on Tuesday night
Joy Reed just said Hillary won in 2016
I I I don't think that she actually just
said that Joy bear one of
them one of the joyless ones all right
but to the judge's point I have in my
notes direct democracy I think that
these referendums should be in all
sanctuaries cities and that part of what
Democrats believe and espouse is that
government is supposed to be reflective
of the people and also things like the
Constitution are living breathing
documents right that you need to update
based on circumstances and these
circumstances have changed dramatically
so ask people what they want and then
you go back to the Biden Administration
and you say this isn't working I think
like the results on those referendums
would be the
same as the abortion referendums in the
red States well but then going to want
to be a sanctuary City want it's too bad
they're suppressing the vote in
Chicago what an attack on Democracy I
can't stand it the fastest is up next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else